103 días tres meses después del
feminicidio de María Belén Bernal la
policía colombiana detuvo en una playa
de la costa caribeña el principal
sospechoso Germán Cáceres sus marido la
madre María Belén agradeció a los
uniformados colombianos y señaló en
medios locales su preocupación ante la
posibilidad de que Cáceres se suicide
durante su traslado demostrando una vez
más que los familiares de la víctima no
confían en la institucionalidad
ecuatoriana
recordemos que el presidente sacó al
ministro de ese momento y Carrillo
afirmó que la Policía Nacional y su
espíritu de cuerpo para no Investigar de
la forma correcta del asesinato de María
Belén el cuerpo sin vida de María Belén
fue hallado el 21 de Septiembre tras
pasar 10 días desaparecida después de
haber sido vista por última vez en la
escuela superior de policía donde
trabajaba Cáceres sus marido denunció la
desaparición fue retenido por unas horas
para ser liberado Poco después la
autopsia determinó que murió por
estrangulamiento y asfixia para entonces
Cáceres ya estaba prófugo de la justicia
y buscado por la Interpol incluso la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos del Estado ecuatoriano
investigar el feminicidio y los
familiares de María Belén iniciaban su
lucha en una búsqueda de Justicia
calificando el hecho como un crimen de
estado este sábado la fiscalía de
Ecuador señaló que una Delegación se
encuentra en el país vecino para
coordinar el traslado a Quito de Cáceres
Germán Cáceres buscado por el
feminicidio de María Belén Bernal ha
sido localizado y capturado mi
reconocimiento al trabajo conjunto entre
la policía de Ecuador fiscalía Ecuador y
la fiscalía colombiana una vez en el
país recibirá todo el peso de la ley el
caso de María Belén es uno más en
Ecuador donde el feminicidio está dentro
del Código Penal desde 2014 y que sólo
en 2022 según datos oficiales hubo casi
300 feminicidios unas cifras que para
los organismos feministas independientes
esconden un gran subre